c'est un des gros chantiers du
quinquennat l'orientation dans le
supérieur avec parcours sud dont les
résultats ont commencé à tomber l'accès
à l'université avec une nouvelle loi
c'est sur ces sujets que nous ouvrons le
débat aujourd'hui dans dimanche en
politique avec des étudiants et la
vice-présidente de l'université
orientation sélection moyens
l'université est elle encore attrayante
on en parle dans quelques minutes restez
avec nous demain opération tous
apprentis france 3 et france bleu se
mobilisent sur toutes leurs antennes
pour valoriser le monde de
l'apprentissage
c'est la meilleure façon de découvrir un
métier la prendre sans le faisant tous
les jours toute la journée
enquêtes reportages magazines et
éditions d'information l'apprentissage
côté pratique des réponses concrètes
si comme on travaille ici de comparer de
changer les idées parce que
l'apprentissage est un avantage et le
partage d'un savoir-faire savez pourquoi
je me réveillais du travail c'est un
plaisir
c'est vraiment une formation complète à
prendre autrement et rendre non réactive
on y est
demain toute la journée sur france 3 et
france bleu
l'apprentissage un tremplin pour
l'emploi
retrouvez toutes les informations sur
région pour un france 3 point fr c'est
lâche tout apprenti ou sur france bleu
point fr
[Musique]
sensation de muscles dure comme du bois
comme de la pierre granions
décontractant musculaire pour mener la
vie dure aux contractures demandez
conseil à votre pharmacien
les gencives protège les zones sensibles
de votants quand elle se rétracte vos
dons peuvent devenir sensible le
dentifrice elmex sensitive réparé
prévient répare les zones sensibles pour
un soulagement immédiat et aident à
renforcer vos gencives
il prévient ainsi toute sensibilité
dispositif médical elmex sensitive
réparé prévient elmex la première marque
recommandé par les dentistes
et voilà vous avez 40 ans
et vous voyez la vie beaucoup plus
sereinement quoi mais aussi un peu plus
flou parfois
si vous êtes né entre 1968 et 1978
venez tester votre vie gratuitement
gigatonnes à table on au titien balle
[Musique]
avec régime box perdait jusqu'à cinq
kilos par mois j'ai perdu 25 kilos en 6
watts hyper simple et on a la garantie
que les plats sont équilibrés j'ai perdu
46 kg en ciment sans privation en ayant
moins de fait quelques artistes car
comment de maintenant et bénéficiez
d'une réduction de 40%
chaque jour vous mangez un délicieux
petit déjeuner un vrai plat le midi un
repas copieux le soir et même une barre
chocolatée à 16 heures la livraison est
gratuite
si vous n'êtes pas 100% satisfait vous
êtes remboursés alors rendez vous sur
régime box point fr et bénéficier d'une
réduction de 40%
c'était la dernière séquence
[Musique]
konichiwa il a servi à midi dansant
restaurant japonais en plein coeur de
bonnes pour une émission entière dédiée
à la culture japonaise à lormont
cuisineront oui bien sûr et puis nous
aurons fait des tacos une percussion
japonaise nous ferons ensuite entre deux
compositions florales
oui c'est l'art de l'ikebana il s'avance
tout ça boissier aujourd'hui à 12h55
pour un euro c'est là en pour une fois
qu'on peut déguster votre programme avec
les produits bio bonne terre
votre magazine avec les véhicules 100%
électriques citroën
[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
les résultats d'orientation dans le
supérieur pour les lycéens ont commencé
à tomber cette semaine nous sommes donc
en plein dans le sujet du jour réforme
de l'orientation avec parcours sup
nouvelles lois ou erreurs pour
orientation et réussite des étudiants et
pour en débattre avec nous sur ce
plateau christelle serré chaussinand
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la vice
présidente de l'université de bourgogne
il vous suivez particulièrement ce
dossier de parcours sup et nous avons
choisi d'inviter les trois organisations
qui à dijon représente les étudiants en
commençant par l'unef d'abord bonjour
bonjour le noir clair merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau lui ni de l'autre
côté de la table
pierre-louis magna bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
ambre adamiak bonjour vous représentez
ici les associatifs et les indépendants
troisième force à 10 ans qui représente
les étudiants rajoutant qu'avant cette
émission nous sommes allés voir les
lycéens et les étudiants au la sortie
des lycées sur le campus des réactions
que vous avez pu suivre et que vous
pourrez suivre sur instagram sur
facebook
et puis on vous en fera écouter quelques
unes dans le courant de cette émission
aussi cette semaine sont donc tombés les
orientations dans le supérieur géré par
le nouveau système parcours fut qu on va
essayer d'être simple pour ceux qui ne
sont pas dedans en ce moment avec des
migraines et et leurs enfants sur le
sujet avant il n'y avait rien ou presque
ensuite il ya eu la plateforme
centralisée abb dont on a dit peut-être
de façon excessive le plus grand mal et
puis maintenant parcours sup
alors comment le résumé très simplement
christelle serait chaussinand
l'université choisit maintenant elle
fixe les exigences on peut le dire comme
ça on peut pas forcément dire qu'elle
fixe céser ses exigences mais par contre
elle elle explicite ce que l'on appelle
les attendus c'est à dire les
compétences nécessaires pour réussir
dans telle ou telle filière et en ce
sens c'est une vraie avancée parce que
c'est attendu là on les avait nous en
tête mais il n'était pas finalement
clarifier auprès des lycéens donc c'est
donc en toute connaissance de cause que
les lycéens vont pouvoir s'orienter vers
telle ou telle licence et pour que ceux
qui nous regardent comprennent bien ça
veut dire qu'à partir de ses attendus
vous vous dites oui ils peuvent venir
chez nous exactement
non ils peuvent pas venir chez nous ils
peuvent venir chez nous à condition qu'
on peut le dire comme ça très simplement
alors il faut dire qu'à l'université 95%
des filières sont non sélective et la
réforme ne change rien à cela elle reste
non sélective un exemple par exemple à
dijon quelque chose de non sélective et
ben vous avez la licence elle a par
exemple langues étrangères appliquées ou
la licence sciences et accueille donc
pour ça on change rien on change
absolument rien et donc ensuite donc si
vous voulez à l'université vous avez
encore une fois 95% de filières non
sélective quelques filières sélectives
c'est par exemple les imiter et pour
l'ensemble de ses formations sur
parcours sup
on a défini une liste de compétences
requises pour réussir et c'est à partir
de cette liste donc d'attendus que l'on
a étudié les dossiers et donc là c'est
une nouveauté aussi puisque avant les
dossiers étaient classés de façon
totalement arbitraire par un algorithme
mathématique totalement inhumain et là
ce sont des équipes pédagogiques qui en
fonction en quelque sorte de règle du
jeu si on pouvait de le dire qui sont
les attendus ont passé en revue les
dossiers et les ont donc classée donc le
classement est on va dire intelligent où
il est fait de façon éclairée
alors on comprend comment ça fonctionne
loup noir clair j'ai lu cette phrase de
l'unef dénonçant une mise en concurrence
des étudiants où vous êtes contre ce
nouveau système est ce qu'on est
finalement dans le coeur du sujet c'est
à dire un système ancien dans lequel le
bac est tel ticket pour entrer puis
maintenant un système dans lequel on
doit finalement quoi choisir son
orientation choisir son avenir ces sacs
dont vous voulez pas mais justement si
nous on demande à ce que l'étudiant
puisse choisir son orientation et
choisir son avenir et contrairement à ce
qui vient d'être dit
c'est très forme c'est linverse l'exact
opposé de de laisser la possibilité aux
futurs étudiants de choisir son avenir
j'ai entendu un système plus humain et
c'est un système soit dix ans en
algorithmes je suis bien content de
l'entendre aujourd'hui parce que il me
semble quand même qu'il ya des algues au
rythme propre à chaque université algues
au rythme tenu secret par ces
universités on n'a pas plus qu'on n'a
pas pu d'ailleurs connaître le contenu
de ces algorithmes pour l'université de
bourgogne
il y à quelques données qui ont pu
fuiter d'autres universités et qui
laisse entrevoir quand même quelque
chose de tout le contraire du main déjà
un classement des étudiants par leur
faim des délices et les futurs étudiants
par leur moyenne au lycée dans certaines
universités aussi en fonction des lycées
dont je vous trouve avant de relancer
sur sur vos camarades mais en même temps
cette façon d'utiliser les résultats du
lycée pour accéder c'est ce qui se
passait pour une part très importante de
lycéens jusqu'à maintenant tous ceux qui
allaient dans des bâches lors tout se
caler dans des prépas de ce qu'elle
aurait certaines filières donc ça
existait déjà finalement est ce qu'il
n'est pas logique de l'étendre à tout le
monde
non puisque le travail soirée du lycée
soit récompensé l'université est
universelle elle doit rester universelle
elle doit rester ouverte à toutes et à
toutes et tous les lycéens et lycéennes
et là ce qui va se produire c'est une
véritable assignation à résidence
sociale une c'est tout à fait c'est le
référé envisagea voulait réagir
président ça concerne 5 % des filières
l'université après on est d'accord pour
pointer les problèmes de parcours sud
c'est à dire un système très opaque ou
par exemple le système de la fiche à
venir
la fiche à venir pour un étudiant pour
un lycéen était connu que le 22 mai en
même temps que ses premières
affectations et malheureusement sous
gouvernement philips est encore un faux
semblants de réformes on essaie
d'instaurer ont dit on va mettre un peu
de sélections pour satisfaire une partie
un peu de la population mais ça règle
pas les problèmes fondamentaux
l'université puisque madame la vice
présidente a dit on ne dit pas non on
dit oui on dit oui si mais on est en
attente en attente d'une place qui se
libère voilà suit un lycéen qui prend le
choix de ne pas honorer son affectation
pour moi après après je pense très
honnêtement que le plus gros problème
de l'installation de parcours sup elle
fait que le gouvernement en fait à
lui-même été pris de court par par
l'installation relativement rapide de
cette réforme est en fait les futurs néo
bachelier en fait se retrouve dans un
état d'anxiété totale parce qu'il ya un
coach pédagogique qui a été loupée à
l'heure actuelle dès qu'on leur a pas
expliqué comment ça allait se passer ils
vont pas tout à fait comment ça allait
se passer
effectivement et le prêt mais ils n'ont
pas compris que leur résultat d'il ya un
an et demi à les poser très très lourd
médian oui alors effectivement à
l'époque c'est pas quelque chose qui
était expliqué parce que personne
n'avait réellement vent mais voilà on se
trouve aussi dans un problème où
l'information c'est très précipitamment
et à l'heure actuelle
et ça je pense que voilà c'est vraiment
global on dénonce que des points
négatifs mais les points positifs sont à
montrer n'y a aucun qui ait mis en ligne
un jeu rebondirait sur sur plusieurs
choses tout d'abord la sélection
existait avant elle existe et si ce
n'est que par cet algorithme inhumain
moi je genre j'en reviens à cela
l'algorithme d'apb c'était ont classé
les jeunes en fonction des voeux qu'ils
avaient fait donc veut 1 2 3 et en
fonction de leur lieu de résidence mais
ça n'est pas satisfaisant c'est bien
encore actuellement cela n'ait pas lieu
de résidence et le cas bien sûr si par
sa jeep au niveau national à un
algorithme qui classe au niveau des
lieux de référence c'est ca c'est quand
même fou quand même pas dire de
c'est un point sur lequel nous ne sommes
pas d'accord et puis l'autre sélection
c'était la sélection par l'échec parce
que si on fait l'économie
le fait d'avoir le baccalauréat et
d'avoir donc le passeport pour accéder
dans le sucre c'est une chose mais on ne
peut pas faire l'économie de
l'orientation
et même si tout n'est pas parfait avec
parcours sup cet engagement on va dire
mutuelle ou qui est convergent des
enseignants du sud qui ont fait l'effort
d'expliciter ce qu'ils attendaient des
jeunes et l'engagement des enseignants
du secondaire qui accompagne à travers
la fiche à venir alors elle aura
peut-être avec eux ni parce que c'est un
reproche qui était fait au lycée ne pas
assez se préoccuper de la suit
exactement
et donc il ya ce si vous voulez de part
et d'autre de la ligne de crête du
supérieur et du sucre du secondaire il
ya cette espèce de on voit l'art on se
met tous ensemble at on pourra
accompagner les jeunes dans leur art je
vous avais parlé de réussite
et justement pour faire la transition
vers la réussite vous propose d'écouter
des étudiants qu'on a rencontré cette
semaine parce qu'ils parlent de leurs
inquiétudes et de la suite on les écoute
tout de suite et puis on en parle
derrière je m'appelle valentin j'ai
manqué un an
je m'appelle manon minier complet mais
des barrières en fait entre différentes
personnes différents niveaux et c'est
l'âge et au plafond c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué avec deux dates de motivation
les sélections des listes d'attentes et
ça doit être impressionnant sportif
il ya beaucoup d'injustices et j'aime ma
cheville est resté sur le carreau
si ces jeunes voulaient aller à
l'université et qui se retrouve à devoir
faire une année de formation je suis pas
sûr que ça corresponde vraiment à leurs
attentes
[Musique]
donc c'est un peu antinomique d'avoir
fac et sélection qui ne savent pas ce
qu'ils vont faire sous prétexte de la
séduction
dans des difficultés puisqu'il est une
pression supplémentaire ce qui beaucoup
d'entre eux réalité stabilisant le
manque de moyens dans notre université
on nous parle souvent des propriétaires
et de ce problème on a vu nos jours de
course due à la baisse on accompagne
régulier de manille sens inverse ainsi
les étudiants permettrait d'éviter la
déroute pour ce soir l'abandon
[Musique]
c'est bien de voir m
c'est bien aussi d'écouter les gens qui
ça concerne derrière forme quand cela
vous étiez un ventre alors plein de
choses dans ce qu'on vient d'entendre
sélection et apprentissage et puis aussi
découragement des étudiants on l'a
entendu et ça renvoie à ce que vous
évoquez
on sait que le taux d'échec en dix ans
c'est 60% je crois à l'université
française
donc est-ce que naïvement d'extérieur on
se dit pierre lui magna et orienter les
étudiants en leur disant vous avez
niveau vous n'avez pas le niveau ce
n'est pas le bon endroit pour vous
est-ce que c'est pas la bonne façon pour
lutter contre l'échec
c'est une des façons c'est un début
c'est un commencement pour noël unis
cette réforme c'est un commencement elle
va pas assez loin tout simplement là une
jeune fille dans votre reportage
elle parle du manque de moyens donc le
manque de moyens c'est simple à
l'université on peut pas pousser les
murs donc c'est soit on a des moyens qui
viennent ma de l'état par d'autres modes
de financement soit on met en place des
systèmes de sélection
c'est triste à dire mais il ya déjà
ainsi un système qui existe c'est la
capacité d'accueil si par exemple on
décide en droit de prendre neuf centres
900 étudiants la première année on prend
pas en compte 950 donc nous à l'uni on
parle de sélection et de sélection au
mérite
basé sur résultats scolaires dossier
tout au long d'un du cursus lycéen est
pas une sélection sur l'argent on est
contre ça puisque l'université on a la
chance en france d'avoir l'université
publique université pour tous qui est
bas vraiment un trésor qu'il faut garder
mais pas ne pas faire n'importe quoi en
encadrant justement avec des barèmes et
les critères de sélection pour élever
l'excellence de l'université oui il faut
plus de moyens pour que les étudiants
réussissons réalité il ya trop
d'étudiants qui savent pas s'ils sont au
bon endroit s'il se plaisent à
l'université qu'elle étudie veut alors à
l'heure actuelle effectivement il ya
énormément moi même depuis f1 qui suit à
l'université depuis quatre ans je m'en
aperçois et notamment quand j'étais en
première année quand on voit le nombre
d'étudiants en fait qu'ils sont présents
uniquement pour pouvoir profiter de la
bourse notamment
alors effectivement à l'heure actuelle
qu'enfin je rebondis sur ce que disait
pierre louis on peut pas pousser les
l'humeur des universités les universités
n'ont pas les moyens déjà et si à
l'heure actuelle il ya toujours des
paliers en d'effectifs qui était qui
était ancré pour les différentes
licences du coup on sort en somme si on
s'appuie là-dessus on peut dire qu'il y
avait une sélection quand même puisque
certains sont restés sans aller dans la
filière qu'il souhaitait cependant je
pense notamment que parcours sup aussi
c'est un début pour casser en fait les
dogmes qui sont présents à l'université
actuellement et ça va permettre d'ancrer
l'université un peu plus sur la réalité
du terrain
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que
effectivement il ya un certain effectif
qui rentrent en licence 1 à la fin de
leur licence donc licence 3 est entré en
master l'effectif est totalement
différent mais on forme à outrance si je
puis dire et les étudiants au final se
retrouve avec un diplôme qui au final
d'un tour pour beaucoup il ne vaut rien
en fait quand il arrive dans le monde
professionnel parce qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de places de disponibles
sur un ace sur le fameux terme
d'adéquation sur lequel on discute dans
la réforme l'adéquation c'est la place
dans les filières par rapport aux
débouchés dans le monde du travail
exact l'unef par exemple s'oppose à
l'idée de l'adéquation loup noir clair
et et finalement ça nous amène à une
question fondamentale sur ce que doit
être universités finalement on comprend
que vous défendez une ligne qui a une
université dans lequel l'étudiant peu
comme on disait dans le temps faire ces
universités c'est à dire prendre le
temps d'étudier de se chercher
et puis il ya une nouvelle ligne qui est
en train d'arriver qui est ça doit nous
mener vers le monde du travail mais moi
j'ai envie de vous dire avant de vous
laisser répondre que les premiers
chiffres de parcours sud montrent que
beaucoup d'étudiants cherche plutôt des
filières sélectives que des filières
ouvertes
est ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
sur un ancien concept qui n'est plus le
voeu des étudiants absolument pas il y
avait dix ans
il ya quelque chose de très longs pu
remarquer actuellement dans le monde du
travail c'est que de plus en plus de
profession de plus en plus de métiers
demandent plusieurs compétences on va
dire demande une pluridisciplinarité des
candidats et c'est justement la force
qu'à l'université
c'est de les former de les former à
cette purée pluridisciplinaire une
pluridisciplinarité pardon également et
justement on dire que l'université
peut-être est dépassée que il faut
instaurer de la sélection que le diplôme
n'a aucune valeur c'est tout à fait faux
puisque justement c'est cette force qu'à
l'université par linda aucune valeur on
en vient aux belges
elle n'a pas utilisé ce terme lc je la
remercie d'abord elle reprend en fait
des positions de l'unir l'aspersion
alors passionné allemand compte c'est un
professionnel en fait doit guider le
meilleur exemple à l'université sa lutte
et du tc une filière sélective sur
dossier
ça a toujours été comme ça mais le taux
d'insertion professionnelle d'un
étudiant qui sort en iut ou même de
poursuite d'études
un étudiant en iut soit il poursuit en
licence professionnelle soit il s'insère
dans le monde du travail et il ya
quasiment aucun échec
quasiment aucun achat compare un peu
l'incomparable parce que l'université
j'avais aussi également jusqu'au
doctorat c'est des milieux qui ne sont
pas du tout pareil je vais prenez
l'exemple de l'insertion professionnelle
c'est pareil un étudiant en droit ça
n'amuse pas de faire cinq ans de masters
juste pour se retrouver au bout de cinq
ans dire qu'est ce que je vais faire
on a le tout le cursus licence à partir
la troisième année on demande à
l'étudiant de choisir soit de droit
public soit droit privé pour après faire
son show en master master en droit
public général ou plus ou plus serré et
après on arrive en master 2 le but c'est
de trouver un job c'est son passe par le
stage revaloriser les stages revaloriser
tout ce qui est insertion
professionnelle donc malheureusement
parcours su laisse de côté l'insertion
professionnelle c'est un des bijoux à la
commencement après je suis bien content
que tu parles de droit moi j'ai un j'ai
un ami qui en master 2 de droit
donc il a passé son bac ya cinq ans il
n'a pas eu du tout de redoublements ou
deux
de changement de filière au cours de sa
de ses études supérieures il avait 10 de
moyenne en terminale le droit est une
filière c'est une filière en tension
dans plusieurs dents mais dans plusieurs
zones des raids ils ont plusieurs
universités en france
les équipementiers les issues tiens je
n'aurais pas fait ce parcours là avec le
nouveau système tout simplement ignorer
que ça s'appelle une réponse est ce que
c'est vrai et et est ce que c'est vrai
que finalement l'université forme pas
les gens donc du travail parce que c'est
comme ça absolument
notre accréditation nous avons notre
nouvelle offre de formation depuis cette
année et les deux maîtres mots de
l'accréditation c'était la
spécialisation progressive c'est à dire
eh bien on passe d'une première année un
peu généraliste à un choix de parcours
mais avec la possibilité éventuellement
de se réorienter et la deuxième valeur
c'était la professionnalisation c'est à
dire ouvrir au monde du travail
donc dans nos licences par exemple en
troisième année
eh bien j'ai régulièrement des étudiants
absents parce qu'ils sont en stage ils
sont dans le milieu professionnel
ce jour ce cas c'est nouveau je veux pas
croire que l'université n'évolue pas et
ne veut et ne bouge pas on se met à la
page
alors le scénario de louis nadal de noir
clair pardon son camarade qui avait 10
en gros ça veut dire au lycée se
cherchait il avait peut-être fait preuve
de maturité d'intérêt et puis qui
finalement réussit bien en droit est ce
mieux et je peux et ce qui est un droit
à l'erreur ou est ce qu'il ya un droit
que la lenteur dans le système mais bien
évidemment bien évidemment alors après
il y a face aux enjeux de on peut le
comprendre je comprends que les jeunes
vous rendez compte l'année terminale
c'est une année extrêmement stressante
il y a le bac il faut faire des choix
d'orientation qui semble
vous vous engagez pour pour la vie bon
et alors donc se développe à certains
fantasmes effectivement on va me juger
sur mes notes dans le travail d'examen
des dossiers qui est fait les
appréciations sont prises en compte la
fiche à venir cette fameuse fiche à
venir dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
quel mon corps c'est que des jeunes et
des parents qui le vivent en ce moment
et pas de danse et bien nous avons
décidé à l'université de la m comme
premier critère d'examen des dossiers
parce que pour moi il me semblait que
c'était un signal envoyé à nos collègues
du secondaire pour leur dire votre avis
nous intéresse également aux familles
pour leur dire bah voilà votre enfant ne
sera pas jugé simplement sur des notes
mais aussi sur des appréciations sur des
motivations mais ce que ça veut dire que
toutes les facultés ne feront pas pareil
et qu'il est en train de se mettre en
place
de grosses différences entre entre
universités en francs et et je ne
parlerai pas pour les autres les autres
résultats complets le problème de cette
fiche à venir c'est que c'est opaque les
étudie les lycéens ont connu le contenu
de cette fiche à venir que le 22 mai
alors en même temps que les affectations
donc c'est un peu problématique est
évidemment pour des étudiants qui sont
inquiets forcément on connaît tous les
lycéens
voilà ma quiétude de la terminale on est
tous passés par là mais se dire ma fiche
à venir je vais être jugée sur ma fiche
à venir puis je connais 30 ans mais
affectation c'est voilà ça c'est un
encore un - pour cette réforme
après excusez moi mais c'est très formel
se met en place elle est quand même
majeurs et ça sera peut-être une des
choses a révisé effectivement je vous
rejoins être dans un enfin une
méconnaissance de ce qui a pu être dit
voilà dans cette fiche je vous rejoins
sur le fait peut-être qu'elles devraient
être connus plus en a le plus apprécié
est un enjeu pour l'université alors
vous avez parlé de la
professionnalisation on le disait tout à
l'heure la sélection elle est pas
nouvelle il ya toute une partie des
lycéens qui depuis des années sont dans
le jeu de cette sélection on va dire
quand même qu'il y avait déjà une partie
de l'université qui sélectionnaient en
pense aux doubles diplômes à toutes ces
choses là
est ce que le fait de mettre ça en place
ça c'est une façon de rendre compétitive
plus respectables l'université on dit
parfois en car et en caricaturant les
meilleurs lycéens c'est clair ils
partent dans les prépas il part dans les
grandes écoles ne vont pas à la fac
donc est-ce qu'il ya cet enjeu là
voir clair ce n'est pas une façon aussi
de redonner du lustre et de niveaux à
l'université la meilleure façon pour
redonner du lustre et du niveau du
niveau à l'université c'est un
investissement dans l'université
actuellement il faudrait le cneser qui
est l'organe principal au niveau
national kiki kirin conseils sur les
questions de l'université conseil de
finances afin d'augmenter le financement
de l'université de hauteur de 1.5
milliard d'euros par an ceci permettrait
de redonner de la hauteur à l'université
s'ils tentaient qu'il en a perdu je vais
revenir sur l'ac pardon mais c'est les
meilleurs élèves n'y allez pas c'est
peut-être qu'ils y trouvaient pas
d'intérêt les meilleurs élèves n'y allez
pas
y at il des chiffres des statistiques au
dessus on sait que s'est développé en
parallèle j'emprunte ap des micros on
sait que s'est développé en parallèle
toute une filière qui est à côté de
l'université et elle existe bien sûr
mais c'est la pluralité des ordres de
formation et c'est bénéfique pour pour
l'enseignement supérieur en général mais
le point fort de l'université je reviens
là dessus c'est son aspect universel qui
est en train d'être perdue avec cette
réforme et qui est en train d'être
perdue de manière non humaine est ce que
quand même vous est ce que vous pouvez
dire qu'il y a quand même des
algorithmes locaux parce que tout à
l'heure vous laissiez transparaître la
fiche à venir etc
y at il des algorithmes locaux alors oui
ou non sur parcours super vous avez nous
avons à traiter une trentaine de milles
de dossiers 30 1697 exactement d'accord
donc sur parcours super il y a un outil
d aide à la décision
mais c'est un outil et c'est un outil
qui vous aident mais qui ne fait pas le
plat sinon ça n'est plus l'algorithme
d'apb qui puis du tout il ya un
algorithme parce que du coup vous ne
répondez pas vraiment y at il à
l'origine la suite de la réponse est non
je suis en train je crois que vous
fantasmez les choses les les attendus
par exemple prenant une licence à la
licence de droit ont parlé du droit tout
à l'heure parmi les compétences requises
pour réussir en licence de droit il
convient de savoir argumenter de savoir
s'exprimer en français de manière
correcte avoir une orthographe correcte
il s'agit de maîtriser une langue
étrangère et puis j'ai oublié les 2 ou 3
attendu qui suivent et bien dans l'outil
des daley décision qu effectivement un
bon nombre de nos formations
on utilise et elles sont allées chercher
dans les fiches à venir ou dans les
bulletins de première et terminale
les appréciations et éventuellement les
notes mais les appréciations en premier
lieu des jeunes sur tout d'abord le
français où l'histoire géo parce que
c'est aussi une matière et ensuite elles
sont allées voir les résultats dans les
langues vivantes
donc c'est ça mais constitue une fois
que ce classement est fêlée les dossiers
sont aux revues par mes collègues et ils
ont épié antastique quand même lui c'est
que vous à l'unef vous indigner pour
cette réforme
mais au moment du tirage au sort on vous
a pas encore bien sûr que si l' on luc
cette réforme est là pour cette réforme
avec vos amis de l'extrême gauche
violente plus organiser les occupations
les dégradations du lca l'université et
sauf qu'en fait la vérité c'est que les
étudiants sur la tentative de blocage en
moins d'une demi heure ils ont débloqué
et ils ont montrés que
un étudiant savez d'étudier et ça veut
réussir et l'enjeu de cette réforme est
de nos discussions c'est la réussite des
étudiants j'ai l'impression qu'à
lunettes vous oubliez aussi le fait
qu'il ya un essor démographique qui est
de plus en plus important jésus en fait
je vois pas trop l'objectif de sa
collection tout à l'heure j'ai quand
même préciser le fait qu'il faudrait
deux milliards d'euros par an dans
l'enseignement des périodes pour faire
ça jour le même souci on revient on
manque des moyens de votre point de vue
c'est quoi l'état d'esprit des deux
étudiants et vous nous direz tous mais
je pense que vous n'êtes pas d'accord là
dessus par rapport à cette réforme par
rapport au fait qu'il y ait cette
nouveauté par rapport à l'université il
ya l'inquiétude mais vous disiez que
l'inquiétude pour les lycéens dans leur
année de terminale l et ça fait des
années que ça dure c'est toujours comme
ça est-ce que les plus forts parce
qu'elle est plus fort parce que c'est
nouveau disque est les plus forts parce
que le système et je pense qu'elle est
plus forte parce que c'est nouveau et
qu'effectivement il ya eu beaucoup de
billets d'informations que ce soit deux
par les médias que ce soit également
dans les lycées parce que vraiment
comprennent ce qui se passe exactement
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est remis
en question depuis des années
l'orientation l'information à
l'orientation et je pense qu'un gros
travail à faire là dessus aussi
et voilà et ça c'est tendance à oublier
qu'il ya dix ans de ça il n'y avait rien
qu'en réalité il ya quand même une
différence énorme sur l'orientation
il n'y avait rien il ya dix ans mais il
ya déjà eu des projets de loi dans le
passé qui visait à amener une amener une
sélection d'entrée d'université c'est
pas quelque chose de marrant 86-86 les
moules aviez vous même utilisé le terme
sélection tout à l'heure l'intensité de
bourgogne parce qu'il nous reste il
pardon je suis désolé mais je me reste 2
minutes 30 d'émission concrètement
l'université de bourgogne va se passer
quoi
combien d'élèves ce que vous avez une
idée de combien d'élèves seront ici et
devront faire une année de misère nous
avons mais la bourgogne alors on va
parler bourguignon oui bien sûr alors on
a on a un beau projet je crois pour les
oui si justement parce que ça c'est une
chance c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas eu
l'occasion d'en parler parce que
effectivement si on n'a pas toutes les
briques de compétences pour réussir dans
telle ou telle licence il ya une
possibilité nouvelles introduites par
cette réforme cette loi est re qui est
en vous accueillant oui si et on vous
donnera dans la première année à
l'université et bien les compétences que
vous n'avez pas pour réussir donc ce
dispositif il s'appelle agila approche
globale d'intégration d'insertion en
licence et est donc voilà on va
travailler sur des compétences
transversales je parlais du français
total ont bien vu combien de combien de
alors ça peut représenter alors nous
avons fait au total 2076 proposition
répond sous la forme de wi 6 1 au niveau
de l'université
c'est un chiffre qui peut par conséquent
sur combien au 2t 1065 2076 sur sur
30000 au label nature parce que c'est
une mise en place vous imaginez énorme
et on escompte peut-être
la rentrée d'avoir 300 400 élèves enfin
étudiant en mauricie
et si ça marche on va le développer
c'est bon et vous attendez la musique
non c'est la scène chez eux obligés de
couper l'eau noire clair c'est la fin de
ce débat parce que je vous l'avais
expliqué si on peut pas on peut pas
négocier sur le temps merci à tous les
quatre d'être venu un débat qui va
rebondir sur les réseaux sociaux sur
instagram sur facebook avec un résumé de
ce débat puis des interviews qui ont été
faits dans la coulisse juste avant cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis
restez avec nous pour la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique juste
après le journal de midi bon dimanche
au revoir et merci
[Musique]
il